when you start to think about uh
regulation you've mentioned a couple
times that politicians just stay out of
it uh i think the counter-argument from
a politician that wants to be very
heavily involved is something like uh
tara or luna
maybe some of the rug polls in the defy
world et cetera how do you balance what
uh i would label as uh more of a
libertarian view on uh keep government
out of this stuff which i think is
probably the dominant viewpoint of
people in the bitcoin community uh with
many of the um you know kind of uh
outlier catastrophes that have occurred
uh in the larger crypto ecosystem like
how do you just balance those two things
yeah so the first thing is you know
these tragedies are are terrible you
know people lose a lot of money
sometimes they lose their life savings
in some cases you know people lose their
lives over it you know it's a very very
serious thing
uh but there's there's two things to
think about one does can the regulation
stop these things you know can
regulation prevent another luna i would
say probably not because bernie madoff
was the biggest fraud of all time and he
was head of the largest regulator so
there's people who are regulated there's
all kinds of frauds enron and other
things so there's a lot of overhead for
these regulations and it's not really
clear it's not like we have a world
where we choose either you know no
regulations or we have regulations then
everything is fine you know everything
is not fine with regulations we still
have fraud but we still but we have this
also huge huge huge burden on society
and on businesses so i would prefer to
not have the regulations and the way
will there be drawbacks of that sure but
there's a lot of advantages you know
about half of the industry spends about
half of its time dealing with compliance
and lawyers you talk to many ceos just
as i do all the time and uh
you know you know that a big chunk of
their time is focused with lawyers and
and compliance and that's a shame now
there's a drain on our economy so people
should be able to have a bit more
freedom and uh you know there's some
drawbacks of that you'll have bad things
happen but you'll also have bad things
happen if you have people like madoff
and other politicians and other people
trying to run your lives you'll also
have bad things happen so either way
you're gonna have bad things happen um i
prefer a market uh system where things
like luna can reset you know people
would not if 2016 or 17 white paper and
tried to market it right now it wouldn't
work because the market has regulated
itself and uh although they've tried
luna 2 i don't think that'll work too
much and i know that we won't see luna
3. unless they really clean up their act
and the market believes it you know
so the market is a very very efficient
regulator in many ways and that's the
regulator that i prefer